what are ten things an aspiring writer
should know about writing
ten things yes number one get a good cup
of coffee sorry
that yeah yeah like could we count that
as one um
so so ten things that any writer should
know about writing
i think i think definitely definitely uh
staying caffeinated certainly helps
um i think experience is
is sort of an obvious one i think
in film school i i found that
a lot of people were making movies about
things that they
knew nothing about and that sort of
bothered me i was always
at least in as an undergrad i didn't
really have much life experience and so
i was making uh
movies for better or worse sometimes
without as much substance but it was
still my experience
so i think experience is is a big one
i think discipline and routine
being uh honest with yourself so honesty
is a big one
oh why sorry to interrupt but why that
one that's really good
i think honesty is really important to
writing
because i didn't really even start to
realize that i was becoming somewhat of
a decent writer until i was
really honest with myself not just you
know
honesty in the sense of you know digging
deep in your heart and telling your
story or anything like that but more so
being honest about your work trying to
be
objective looking at it and sort of
knowing deep down
or at least telling yourself deep down
what you really think
of your work your writing or your
creation
uh i sort of found myself i don't want
to say lying to myself but i would
write something and be like this is the
best i can do it's it's good enough
and as more and more time went on i
started to sort of
say to myself no i can actually do
better and i think that that
that is that comes with experience and i
think that's part of just being honest
with yourself
admitting that you can do better
awesome i think okay so four so
caffeinated oh is that four i thought
that was five
oh sorry okay i must have missed one in
there okay um
man this is a good question sorry i'm
not just like rolling out with the uh
the answer is uh
can i say travel i think travel is
important
um meeting all sorts of different types
of people
uh that certainly inspires the
characters that i write
i guess routine and discipline was one
that i already said but i think it's
equally as important to be open to
breaking that routine
to having this sort of spontaneous fire
inside of you that makes you want to do
something you've never done before
i spent a lot of my
college years and post-grad years you
know
focusing on comedy and only now
at 32 am i actually diving into horror
and i find that i'm actually really
enjoying it and it's not something that
i ever
imagined wanting to do but i think being
open to
changing you know your trajectory of
things
is is a good thing so spontaneity
and uh what is that eight i believe so
seven or eight yeah yeah i've drawn a
blank on the last two
i think having a good uh word processing
program
certainly helps i think uh
i think maybe that just contributes to
the structure of things but i feel
i feel a little bit more inspired if i
have just the proper equipment
to write that is a laptop personally i
don't i don't do like pen and paper or
anything like that
and uh you know final draft or celtx or
something like that
um that's a way more technical answer
and i think the last thing is arguably
the most important
which would just be the passion the
desire to do it
i think you're gonna have a lot of
trouble if you are
are not enjoying some part of it
i think it's normal to enter into
periods where you are like i hate this i
want to move on to the next thing
already
i think accepting that but still
reminding yourself of why you
started this to begin with is super
important and if you have that then you
can fall back on it
and i think you will be able to finish
just about everything that you start
excellent going back to number eight
about having the proper
like writing implements or whatever have
you ever tried to do a script or write a
script just using pages or word
and not using um like a software program
uh i i have the i think the last time i
i get i guess i should say when i was
maybe when i was like 10 or 11 i would
actually
write books and i would start by
grabbing a whole stack of paper and
folding them and then stapling it
and then i would draw pictures and i
would actually draw like write my
story in those books so i basically at
the end
at age 11 had a self-published single
copy of my book
um and then since then i
i've probably used you know word a
couple times and i've scribbled ideas in
in notebooks and i even like on my phone
right now i have a notepad of
ideas that i can scroll for days um
but when i actually sit down to write a
screenplay now it's mainly just
final draft excellent okay
great by the way do you have those books
still that you did
i got to ask my parents i think we left
those in our basement in massachusetts
uh and i i'll ask if they cleaned it out
or if they kept them
i hope they kept them yeah